oui moi
la surprise est totale au kansas
c'était un conservateur traditionnel
bastion des anti avortement a dit non un
changement de la constitution de l'état
près de 60% des électeurs ont refusé que
ce droit à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse soit restreint voire éliminer
je suis très fier d'être du kansas et
relie athlètes la campagne pendant ce
référendum fut des plus intenses pour
convaincre l'électorat et contre toute
attente elle a permis de jauger la
mobilisation des partisans démocrates et
progressistes mais pas que
[Musique]
la victoire est obtenue 10 h les hommes
grâce à une coalition d'électeurs de
droite et de gauche qui ont dit non ces
politiques extrêmes
les républicains locaux dénoncent ce
qu'ils ont appelé la campagne de peur
orchestrée par les pro choix ceux qui
ont fait campagne pour les restrictions
à l'avortement n'ont pas dit leur
dernier mot belron mais brad thompson
les pro choix dit-il se sont acheté
juste un peu de temps
depuis que la cour suprême a invalidé le
droit à l'avortement et laisser le choix
aux états de légiférer en la matière les
démocrates fourbissent leurs armes en
vue des élections de mi mandat de
novembre prochain l'enjeu de l'accès à
l'avortement semble porter cette semaine
le département de la justice a poursuivi
l'état de l'idaho qui s'est doté d'une
loi des plus restrictives
cette loi dit il viole une loi fédérale
sur les urgences médicales auxquelles
font face les femmes qui doivent se
faire avorter
et puis pour la deuxième fois quelques
semaines joe biden a signé un décret
présidentiel pour garantir un accès à
l'avortement cette fois ci pour garantir
que les femmes qui voyagent à
l'extérieur de leur état pour obtenir un
avortement puissent avoir accès aux
services de santé appropriés une dizaine
d'états ont déjà banni les avortements
sur leur sort les à terme la moitié des
50 états forcément républicains feront
de même
le résultat de ce référendum mettra-t-il
un frein aux ardeurs des anti avortement
les démocrates espèrent en tout cas que
le réveil des progressistes au kansas
s'étendre à un peu partout et leur sera
bénéfique dans moins de 100 jours
lorsque la majorité des sièges au
congrès seront remises en jeu ici
frédéric arnould radio canada à
washington